today's video is a little bit longer
than normal but if you like my work do
make the time to either watch or listen
all the way through
in spite of my voice starting to give
out and crack a bit part way through
this one and a little recording glitch
near the end that makes steven sound
like he's calling from the bottom of the
ocean this is in my opinion the best
video on my channel the crowning jewel
of stated casually in part this is
because steven and i got along super
well he was really great to present with
but also
a lot of the information here has never
been presented in a form that's
accessible to the general public the
papers that i base my presentation on
can be easily found online but if you
don't have a good grasp of biochemistry
those papers are really hard to
understand
i'm not shy to say this video is an
important contribution to the public
conversation about genetics
so why did stephen and i get together
and record this well the past almost 10
years i have had what you could call a
secret hobby whenever i hear a public
figure talk about genetics or genetic
research incorrectly instead of
complaining about it on twitter i will
call or email the person this might be
youtubers journalists radio hosts public
health officials creationists you name
it
in my first contact i introduce myself i
explain briefly and in the friendliest
possible manner
what the error is and why i think it's
worth correcting and then i offered to
meet privately confidentially to discuss
as you might imagine in some cases my
emails are simply ignored but usually
that's not the case i almost always hear
back from people and sometimes we do
actually meet
stephen woodford better known by the
name of his youtube channel
rationalityrules is the only person who
has wanted me to record and then publish
our conversation he did that because he
really cares about transparency he cares
about intellectual honesty i am a long
time fan of steven's channel rationality
rules he discusses atheism and
philosophy with a focus on the logic and
the fallacies that people use in their
arguments
he's even produced a really cool card
game called debunked you can learn about
that and buy it at debunkedcardgame.com
the conversation you're about to hear
led us to remake a video that he had
done on dna the original had several
errors in it in the video description
below you'll find links to our new video
just now published on his channel the
title and thumbnail might be different
from what you're seeing here but the
link should work and there is a link to
the old video that we replaced he
delisted it from youtube's search
results so it won't continue to give out
bad info but for the sake of full
transparency he asked that i give you a
direct link so you can still watch that
there's a bunch of great stuff in our
conversation we start by talking about
the argument creationists have been
making where they claim that dna is
evidence for god his first video aimed
to debunk that argument and part of his
video was great but he missed a few
important issues and some of the things
that he said were just not correct i do
a general overview of biological
communication systems so communication
systems that naturally evolved we then
talk about signaling theory and
during that part of the conversation we
go off on a little tangent about some
trouble that he got into when he was
criticizing certain aspects of the
transgender movement
and finally i present what we do and do
not know about the origin of the genetic
code stephen was the perfect person for
this conversation he had lots of
questions great insight and he wasn't
shy to push back when he disagreed about
my views or tactics on how to best deal
with the anti-evolution crowd so you
will get to witness a bit of atheist
versus atheist combat here which is
always fun and i'm sure creationists
will get a kick out of seeing some
infighting
without further ado i give you the great
stephen
woodford
welcome it's it's super cool to have you
on it seems like it's more and more rare
maybe i'm just noticing it more for
people to actually want a different
point of view we have this pride issue
that doesn't let us want to do this as
uh chucky d behind you that lovely
drawing that you did
we bear the stamp of our lowly origin
and part of that lowly origin is just
not being able to admit when you get
something wrong and you know it's like
no no
you can't calmly educate me john that's
that's not okay
but um no thanks for reaching out it's
it's always a pleasure i've been a fan
of your content for as long as i can
remember
watching youtube uh so when you reached
out to me i was like oh man this is
awesome but also oh no i got something
wrong it actually reminds me of when
matt de la hunty reached out to me for
the first time i was like
what matt delahanty just reached out to
me and he was telling me i was wrong on
something and i was like this is this is
a trend i've got to stop
but no um seriously thanks for reaching
out like we're going to put this correct
and actually one thing that i think is
worth doing
is i will unlist the old video
after this call and
i will start remaking the the remastered
version
and if you'd be willing and able i'd
love for you to look over the script to
look over the execution and just
basically make sure that i get it right
so if you're up for that that'd be
amazing well thank you very much yeah do
you consider your channel like an
atheist channel or a philosophy channel
how do you yeah good question um i i
would say
i would say
yes it is part of the atheist community
but more so especially in recent time
i'm just going my own way doing
philosophy and whatnot but it's
definitely part of the atheist community
and like i'm a proud member of that and
i'm happy to associate with i've seen
some of my colleagues disassociating
themselves from new atheism but i'm like
no i'm fine with that that's all good
so you know i would say it's an atheist
channel
or an atheist perspective on
philosophical investigations like you
can put it that way or just you know
attacking theists whatever you wish
i really appreciate your channel i do
recommend it for anyone who hasn't gone
over there to see it rationality rules a
lot of the things on there are atheist
arguments but even if you're religious
it's cool to listen to these arguments
and try and digest them that's good for
you
right yeah we'll see yeah
so there is this problem
that's that i've been noticing
for years now
every time i talk about the genetic code
in my videos people will argue in the
comments christians will say that the
genetic code is evidence of god i'll get
atheists say no the genetic code isn't
really code or it's not really anything
like a language or a code that's just an
analogy that scientists use
and that's the argument that atheists
have been making the thing that hurts my
heart
about that argument is that there are
some incredible linguistic properties
about the genetic code like really
fascinating things about it
that we're throwing out when we try and
make that argument because
most creationists use their definitions
kind of weird
there are ways to make an argument and
say that oh you're just using the word
language
to confuse yourself and in many cases
that's actually partially true but there
really are genuine linguistic properties
about the genetic code
that demand an explanation and so
creationists even if they're even if
they're technically wrong about like why
it is that they think genetic code is
special they are right to think the code
is special because it really is the goal
that i have today is to explain what
those
special linguistic properties are
and what we do know and don't know about
how they formed through the evolutionary
process so well what i'll do then is i
will work as a uh
as a good old sound board i'll throw
questions your way of course and are
trying to explain more why
like if you're a creationist that's
watching this or just someone that
doesn't accept evolution
i don't know if that's the same thing
but if you were if you're watching this
and you're thinking why is it that
atheists say this i think i might be
able to get you to understand that
perspective a bit better
um so hopefully this is just
something that helps everybody with
clarity really yeah yeah
this is actually from your video you you
lay out the syllogism so creationists
have have framed this argument in lots
of different ways
but you broke it down really nicely and
you're saying that the main points
they're making they're saying that
language is a product of a mind it's
always a product of a mind and sometimes
they'll say code instead so code is a
product of mine or language is a product
of a mind
dna is a language or dna is a code
therefore dna is a product of a mind so
that is the argument that creationists
are making when they try to say that the
genetic code is evidence of
intelligent design and the part of this
syllogism that you attacked in your
video is you attacked the idea that dna
is a language or the genetic code is in
the code is has these linguistic
properties
and that's actually the wrong premise to
attack it is true that
sometimes the way that they're using
their defining terms as weird there are
ways to attack it but there really are
linguistic properties about the genetic
code that are special and the the thing
that we should be
addressing is that languages are not
always the product of a mind we actually
know of another process the process of
evolution happens to be that can also
generate
signal based or symbol-based
communication systems and this is well
understood at this point in history
there are details about the actual
origin of the genetic code that are not
super well understood but we do
understand in principle how things like
the genetic code can emerge through the
process of evolution that's where
this argument should be made because the
creationists are wrong and their their
conclusion is wrong
but
for a different reason than most
atheists are saying
well i can expand on on this a bit which
will probably be helpful so if you take
another argument that's used for the
existence of a god
uh say the kalam you know premise one
whatever begins to exist has a cause
premise two the universe began to exist
conclusion therefore the universe had a
cause
uh then there's like stage two where you
try and derive from stage one the
properties of what that cause would be
and that's where you're meant to get to
uh god a divine being with you know the
properties that you find you know
omnipresence omnipotence etc
now
when addressing the kalam
the way in which someone uses a word
can
very often determine which premise
the contention is on
so for example it depends on how they
define universe so if they was to define
universe as our local space a space-time
manifold
then that's a very different claim to
saying the totality of everything so to
contextualize this with this argument
for me it depends on who i'm interacting
with as to which premise to focus on and
what i'll try and expand upon as we get
through a few more slides is that i
actually think that focusing on premise
two here is correct depending on who
you're talking with but because i
focused exclusive exclusively on that i
do entirely realize that i i missed a
trick with the first premise and in
doing so i gave this impression or maybe
even just straight up ignored the fact
that there are these wonderful
properties with dna which absolutely do
count as a language if it's defined in a
certain way so yeah i just wanted to
give you a bit of resistance on that
front because i think i think that's
where a lot of the contention's
happening there's a lot of
miscommunication well not so much
miscommunication but there's a lot of
conversations happening at once
referring to this argument
it is true that there are lots of
different definitions of the word
language and i'll talk about that here
in a second
different fields of science that study
languages and language-like systems they
use actually different definitions and
there's a lot of confusion around this
subject but i really don't like
attacking premise number two and maybe
i'm too hardcore with this like maybe i
need to back off a little bit maybe it's
okay to attack premise number two but
the reason it breaks my heart when
people do this is that there really are
these linguistic properties that the
genetic code has that are spectacular
and i don't want that baby tossed out
with the bathwater i want to steal man
the creationist argument i want to say
yes the genetic code is very
language-like it's got linguistic
properties but we now know that things
that are like languages they don't
always have to come from minds these
things can come about naturally and
scientists now understand this process
very very well i like to steel man
their argument
yeah i like i like that i think that's
um
yeah i'm totally on board of that and i
definitely would say that my first video
did not still mana whereas what i can do
now is by addressing both horns various
definitions of how language is used you
can absolutely look at the stronger
claim where dna absolutely is a language
and it does cry out for
for
well
if
admiration at the very least it's like
yeah it's like saying a crazy sunset or
mountain range it's just um
for me
i mean
the
it takes a little bit of uh
you got to learn some biochemistry to to
really understand how spectacular it is
but once you understand it's like wow
this is this is really amazing
no wonder people are
trying to use this anything that
inspires ah people will use for
religious um i mean that's that's that's
the religious feeling is this feeling of
awe that we get when we're looking at
something amazing that's where awesome
comes from yeah
there are two false claims that
creationists are making that are
separate claims and your video also sort
of conflated these two but they also
conflate them when they're making them
so
one claim is the creationist will say
that it's impossible for new genetic
information to evolve information can
only be created by thinking minds so
that's that's one thing and your video
actually addresses that
gene sequences can easily change the
information in a genome can change just
through the process of evolution
the second claim that they're making
which is a very different claim is that
languages and codes can only be created
by thinking minds and that if the
genetic code is a language or a code it
must have been made by god
that second one you sort of brushed
aside this is the difference here so
here this this box that i'm showing you
here this is what we call the genetic
code this is basically the dictionary of
the genetic code there are 64 symbols in
the genetic code or 64 words and it is
this language these these symbols that
have been assigned each symbol each
codon is what each symbol is called
they're called codons and they are three
dna nucleotides or rna nucleotides and
they have been assigned somehow
throughout the history of evolution to
represent 20 different types of amino
acids there's also a start command and a
stop command these allow genes to send
messages and messenger rna to ribosomes
which can read the embedded information
in the chain of rna and they read it
according to these rules this genetic
code here this chart here
the fact that we have symbols here that
are not just dictated by physics they're
actually dictated by the evolved
structure of the ribosome and transfer
rnas these things had to be assigned
through an evolutionary process or i
suppose they could have been assigned
through an intelligent design process as
well but there had to be an assignment
that happened of these symbols to
the amino acids that they represent
and for those of you listening and
you're like what the heck does all that
mean that sounds like
crazy talk
don't worry we're going to go over this
in detail i'm just kind of giving you a
taste here this is the question we want
to ask how were codons assigned their
specific meanings that is the
the special question that creationists
are right to ask this guy sumo oh no he
focused on how new genetic information
evolves his big i don't know if it was
really his discovery but he he really
drove on the importance of gene
duplication in the process of evolution
and the process especially in our genome
there's tons of genes that have been
duplicated and then slightly modified
after duplication through point
mutations and so on he showed not just
how you get new versions of information
that already existed but how it is that
the genome of an organism of a species
will expand it might be uh useful to
give an example a very tangible physical
example of something that is new genetic
information okay one really good example
of new genetic information that evolved
through a gene duplication followed by
point mutations would be the venom
molecules that snakes have a lot of them
are normal genes that all tetrapods have
so all backboned vertebrates have that
have been duplicated and the duplicate
is expressed in their saliva glands and
so you've got a molecule it's actually
there's there's signaling molecules a
lot of them that our bodies use
you know cells will use to signal to
each other to make sure that
everything's running properly and the
snake just injects those in high
concentrations into our blood and that
causes chaos in our bodies and it causes
it makes us die a bunch of these not all
of them but a bunch of the venom
molecules are just normal housekeeping
proteins that the snake already had they
were duplicated yeah and expressed in
its saliva glands and it's now used as
venom and there are little point
mutations and
things that have happened in those genes
in the millennial sense being
incorporated into the venom that
actually make them more potent i've got
an animation on that how does new
genetic information evolve and it's part
two in that series where i talk about
the venom specifically yeah it's one of
my favorite videos that you've made um
but just to get further clarity on that
does that mean that from the very moment
there was a mutation that's that's
genetic information and does it have to
count as new sorry new genetic
information and does it have can it only
count as new genetic information
if it helps the organism uh proliferate
and succeed or is basically every
mutation classed as a new
new genetic information even if it's a
duplicate or something that was already
there
well i mean
the information itself if you if you
really want to get
like
technical on what what we mean when
we're talking about information in
biology when we're talking about
information we're talking about sequence
information this sequence of
uh nucleotides so in that in that case
it doesn't even matter if it's adaptive
or not if it's if it's changed
it's new
but
uh if you want to talk about adaptive
information functional new functional
information then yeah you'd want to say
that it has to be useful to the animal
um so
this snake example is
a really good example of the hardest
case you know it's it's not just new
information it's new functional
information that's helping that organism
survive and reproduce this guy's work
was absolutely amazing we already knew
that about point mutations they edit
existing information
but this is how you expand it really
rapidly and there are other ways to
expand it too but this is how it happens
really rapidly and there's lots of signs
when we look into the human genome and
the genomes of any organism that this is
is a major process in evolution in the
formation of new genetic information
carl woes focused
really on the ribosome which is that
structure i was showing earlier his big
focus was on the ribosome and he wanted
to understand how the genetic code
evolved he talks about codon assignments
how were these codons assigned their
meaning
and
that will make sense later on in this
presentation if that doesn't make sense
to people right now he
discovered some really cool things
during his career he didn't totally
solve the problem in all of the detail
that we would want it to be solved and
it's actually still being worked out but
the general principles we now understand
quite well
because of his work and because of the
work of others in a sub-field of
evolutionary biology called signaling
theory we have a really good
understanding of how codes can evolve
naturally in your video you you
conflated those two and then you you
mainly focused on the the origin of new
genetic information and
for the creationists that wanted to know
your argument about the origin of the
genetic code itself this actual system
they would have been disappointed you
know i said earlier i was going to get a
few bits on the table i think here is a
good place to put it so if you are a
theist listening that's you know not
someone who's on board with evolution
then what i'm about to explain might
explain
or give detail of
why i took the approach that i did
consider this right if we define
language as to be a product of
intelligent design it follows that if
dna is a language then dna is
necessarily a product of intelligent
design
we can put this into a deduct into a
deductive form into the deductive form
of modus ponens we can say which which
is by the way if p then q p therefore q
so
if there is a language p then there is
an intelligent designer q
dna is a language p therefore an
intelligent designer exists q
now technically it might be the case
that this designer created the language
of dna and then no longer exists but
hopefully you get the point here
now in my experience this is what the
vast majority of theists are actually
arguing and this is especially true when
you're looking at the likes of ken ham
and
hovened like this is this is the way
that they argue they they define
language as to presuppose
intelligence is something that we've
touched upon a little bit earlier on uh
my first my question to you john is like
is that your experience as well do you
find that is the most prominent horn
that's taken here they define language
as to presuppose uh intelligent design
or do you find that's not the case now i
find that that is the case and so my and
i was talking about this with richard
dawkins as well
my instinct and this is this is his too
is instead of trying to say that dna is
not language or that the genetic code is
not language or coding system
instead just focus on the fact that well
yeah it is a coding system it does have
linguistic properties but guess what we
know how those sorts of things evolve
editors note my conversation with
richard dawkins was actually a little
bit different we were talking about the
claim that the genetic code really is a
code like the code that's found in
computers and how the atheist movement
has been arguing that that's actually
not the case that the genetic code is
only an analogy to code the following is
richard's response to his fellow
atheists
now i think that's the wrong approach i
think it is a code it's definitely a
code um and it is a code that's put
together
not by a designer but by natural
selection it's very easy to see how that
can happen in principle details of
course need to be worked out but
nevertheless there is no problem in
saying that dna would be a code in just
the same kind of way as a computer code
it certainly is a code
um
you can read it as a code you could you
could even transcribe i think i put this
in river out of eden could even
transcribe a book
into
dna letters now the argument i'm setting
out here with stephen is different i'm
saying that it's okay to call the
genetic code language but well you'll
hear my reasoning here
so i'd like to play a couple of clips
and the first clip is this is from a
video titled science confirms the bible
and it's from everyone's favorite
answers in genesis ken ham so we'll play
that and then and then i'll give you a
few comments
and you know one of the things that we
found out
languages only ever come from an
intelligence and information only ever
comes from information dna cries out
that there's an intelligence behind life
it couldn't have happened by chance
random processes matter on its own could
never produce dna but if life evolved
matter had to produce dna but that could
never happen
so ham's statement of languages only
ever come from intelligence that's a
direct quote
it translates to
languages p implies an intelligent
designer q
given this would you agree with me in
saying that according to this definition
dna is not one
yes i agree with you you are correct
that if we are going to define language
as something that only comes from a
human mind or a human-like mind then
yeah the genetic code obviously is not
that and i also agree with you that a
lot of people define language in that
way that's kind of casually how we think
of language but what we have discovered
in biology over the past several hundred
years is that language systems
language-like systems can emerge
naturally
yeah i mean like another way of putting
this with his argument is um that
effectively the conclusion of
intelligent design is presupposed by the
premise by the definition of language
that he's using and plus the argument is
just begging the question that one
premise does all of the work on its own
but what you said there is that you'd
have to deny the premise and that means
you're focusing on the premise that i
focused on
so you would have to focus on the
premise that i focused on because you
don't get to define their arguments and
their language for them you have to meet
people where they're at and if people
like ken ham are explicitly using
definitions of languages that
pre-suppose
uh intelligent design then um maybe i'm
missing something but it seems to me
that with that type of creationist with
that type of argument it is correct to
focus on that premise as much as it
irritates you or it irritates everyone
else because they are effectively
forcing us to throw away the or the
lovely properties of the of dna and it
seems to me that it is correct to focus
on that premise
do you think i'm wrong on that because i
want to make sure that we're clear on
that
i think okay if you're having a
conversation with someone who's willing
to listen to you
i don't think ken ham is that type of
person but um
in my observations of his behavior in
the past but if you are having a
conversation with someone who's willing
to listen to you
i i think it's it's great to say look
you are correct in being like wooed and
odd by the fact that the the genetic
code has linguistic properties that is a
correct emotion to have
however
the the the idea that languages only
come from minds is is simply false
these same properties can come about in
another way
we now know this we didn't know this 100
years ago but we do know this now so
that would translate to you saying to
them
you please rephrase your first premise
your first parameter is incorrect okay
yeah yeah exactly um yeah yeah so i just
wanted to make sure that um i didn't get
that part of the argument wrong which is
which is good but i totally accept that
i absolutely should have touched on the
other horn uh
the second clip i want to play and it's
just one more to give an instance of
what i'm what i'm um
the tree i'm barking up here is from
john lennox john lennox is seen as an
apologist that's a bit more on the c s
lewis side he's a bit more softer he
speaks through narrative and
um story but we'll play the clip here
and then i will uh i'll extrapolate from
his words
the exact same argument as ken ham
but you see there's one area
where the simple to the complex
explanation does not work
and that is the area where language is
involved
if you see your name written on long
beach or something four or five letters
of your name you infer immediately
upwards to an intelligent input no
matter what mechanism put that there you
do that now the fascinating thing and i
often uh suggested to my fellow
professors i say look you go into your
laboratory
and you see the dna with 3.5 billion
letters in exactly the right order and i
ask you what's the origin of that and
you say chance of necessity
when you'll see anything with language
on it four or five letters and
immediately you say intelligent input
all right so
it's harder to spot lennox's premises
right but um since his argument and the
reason it's harder is because he shrouds
his argument in narrative in the story i
don't think he does it
with bad intent it's just the way that
he speaks right you see this with a lot
of apologists as well they do just speak
like this we're a narrative driven
species right so we're gonna we're gonna
do better with analogy and story rather
than hard cold logic
but when he says
if you see your name written on a long
beach or something four or five letters
of your name you infer immediately
upwards to an intelligent input he is
expressing that if you see a language p
then this implies intelligent design q
lennox argument is the same as ken ham's
it's just veiled in a humble clothing
so just want to emphasize that when it
comes to kenham john lennox and i think
as you agree most creationists or most
anti-evil boys and girls um
it does it is coming down to the fact
that they're defining language in a way
that dna we can't say that dna is a
language according to that because if
you if you do that's your entire
argument done you just need that premise
you don't need any other premises right
so it's begging the begging the uh the
question and the whole ques and the
whole
emphasis here is meant to be on does the
dna requirement require um an
intelligent creator and like the science
is saying no it doesn't but if you grant
the definition that they're using which
is effectively the first premise then
we're over with that's where the entire
battle is fought so i just wanted to get
this all on the table and hopefully that
better explains to
uh the person who reached out to you or
forget his name where he made a response
to me um yeah yeah psycho yeah i i hope
that uh gives him a good response and i
imagine he gets frustrated with it as
well i know i would be if
you know you're trying to focus on no
listen like this is a really complex and
really interesting thing and yet the
story is being pushed towards one side
so
psy if you want to understand why
atheists have been saying what i've been
saying in the past um
i would consider the fact that it might
be that we're replying to the majority
of creationists and you're not the
majority
yeah yeah so i i did a debate with t
jump about this too and he was making
that same he basically made the same
argument he said that creationists this
is what creationists mean when they say
it so
he was fighting against what he thinks
creationists mean when they say that the
genetic code is language
but that the big argument that i'm
trying to make is that we we don't need
to just let them get away with defining
language as having to come from
intelligent mind we can just stop and
say look languages don't have to come
from intelligent mind that's where the
error is and the creationist thinking we
know of another way they can come about
so when you when you really think about
it and you can correct me if i'm getting
this wrong like i know we've spoken
about this before but you had william
paley and the teleological argument that
was saying look if you're walking along
and you find a watch on on on the beach
you know immediately you infer
immediately that it was made by
intelligence what was effectively being
said there is look at the human hand
look at the human eye look at the
complexity look at how perfectly
formed it is to work in the way that it
does this screams out for intelligent
design
and what happened is with with the
voyage of you know the beagle and with
darwin and the subsequent discoveries
that we've made we've got to the point
where we went no we actually know
exactly how this is made right
and that is by natural selection and the
evidence for it is utterly overwhelming
these days most christians accept
natural selection they accept evolution
so you know brilliant right you know you
can have this part of god's mechanism
for how he created
um species
that comes with different problems but
but you get the point
but the main takeaway here is that we
could not figure out how this stuff was
made it's incredibly complex
and what we did is we is a god of the
gaps it's the biological teleological
god of the gaps we said therefore god
must have done it
then natural selection occurs and we
figure out no this this could be
explained by natural selection and and
subsequently we've learned that it
almost certainly is described by and and
did come about by natural selection
and what happens now is we go back a
stage
the god of the gaps retreats
and the next retreat is the code itself
where you have this language as you say
uh where there is these communications
between symbols and interpretations from
different different parts of biology and
this is where the argument is exactly
the same because you like look at john
lennox there he's even talking about
seeing
a message in the sand may as well be a
watch it's the same thing
um and to me what i would say is that
look if you're a theist
please just recognize that this argument
was upheld for a very very long time
and was held upheld to be absolutely
solidly the case
and
now that we've learned the lesson that
it was wrong
if there's any takeaway it's not to make
that mistake again and i would i would
say that that alone is a very good
argument not to be doing this with the
genetic code because once we discover
how that's figured out i mean you can
still have that as part of a theological
story in fact i don't really know what
else they're paying in terms of ontology
there they've already paid the high
price of accepting natural selection
which you know comes with a big burden
of the problem of evil so
but yeah i don't want to rant too much
but but it is the same thing yeah yeah i
agree it's the same thing and my
argument to to atheists that are making
the the genetic code is not really a
language or it's not really a code
argument is that if we were to talk
about paley's watch if the argument were
things as complicated as watches are
only created by intelligent minds the
human body is more complicated than a
watch therefore the human body was
created by an intelligence you would
easily know which premise is the stupid
one there right it's easy obviously that
the one is that we we actually know of
another way that complex things can be
produced it's that first premise that's
wrong human minds can make watches
but also natural selection can make
things as complex and more complex than
watches and so that's that's that's what
i'm trying to convince the atheist
movement to start doing is like look if
you want to make this argument argue
about the idea that language only comes
from thinking minds that's that's not
true the thing about the watch
paley's watch is that your intuition
does tell you that this was created by
another person because we are people and
we create things all the time and when
you see a system with linguistic
properties at the very heart of biology
the genetic code when you see that if
you don't know better it does make you
want to say what the heck that how did
a language get inside of our cells
that's weird but once you understand how
it works it's mind-blowing and it's
amazing so that's that's what i want to
talk about here yeah that's um
it's very interesting i've noticed that
compared to most people i don't have
that intuition
so hugh made a really good point on the
teleological argument he said uh he said
look if he was to find a watch
it is not the case that you think
the
the the way that you infer that that is
a product of intelligent design is
because we have
every single example of those watches
being made by by humans
we have zero examples of them emerging
naturally
but when you look at something in nature
i mean how many how many people do you
know how many things do you know that
have made biological structures none
yeah i agree with you like that
intuition doesn't have to
always come but for a lot of people it
does oh i'd say for most i think you're
right most people have that intuition
yeah which is why that that
the watch argument was so successful
yeah for so long well a bit of trivia i
actually think that the william paley's
watchmaker analogy is found in cicero as
well
and a few others i actually think it's
the best argument theists have ever had
and i think that if i live before darwin
it's the the argument that might have
got me there
um however you can look at the works of
people such as percy bishelly he's got
an amazing essay titled a refutation of
deism if you haven't read it read it
it's phenomenal here he preempted
natural selection and it's just
oh just pure
magic he is himself an argument for god
the existence of that of that uh that
rebuttal is too good to not have come
from a god that's the one that's the one
okay
when people are talking we actually
conflate
languages and messages written in
languages all the time it's as common as
saying that the sun rose you know the
sun doesn't actually rise the earth
spins right we all know that and a lot
of times we will we'll do this when
we're talking about languages as well so
here i'm saying hey look i wrote english
and i've got queen elizabeth here saying
no you used english to send a written
message to english readers
another example of this is i wrote
javascript and i'm showing off some
javascript that i wrote here and then
brendan ike the guy who actually wrote
javascript is saying no you use
javascript to send a message to a
browser so if we want to be really
careful in how we're using our word we
don't talk about the human's genetic
code
codes for blah blah blah
we would say that the sequence of the
human genome
codes for certain proteins because the
genetic code itself is the language and
then
the actual gene sequences that we have
those are specific messages
using the language of the genetic code
does that make sense yeah yeah i'm
getting you drift there and you're right
like people do this so often and uh yeah
i'm i'm one of them if you look at most
textbooks even like biology textbooks
they'll confuse a sequence of dna with
code they'll call it code and i've done
it in some of my videos too it's just
kind of like the looseness of language
that we that we use
yeah totally there are three really cool
discoveries that have been made in the
20th century or really they they kind of
blossomed in the 20th century people
were making discoveries along these
lines even earlier but
one of them is that symbol or signal
based communication systems are
everywhere in biology and thinking minds
are not required to operate them so what
i mean by that is languages they're
they're everywhere in biology you don't
need a thinking mind to operate them
here's an example these flowers are
signaling systems they are sending
signals to pollinators to attract them
over there essentially saying i've got
nectar come get it that's that's what
the insect is interpreting what the what
the flower thinks it's saying is come
pollinate me the sender and the receiver
actually understand slightly different
things but the
the end goal ends up being the same the
pollinator gets nectar which is what
they're after and by accident they also
pollinate this flower because they're
going to all the different species of
the same flower the nectar that they
just got from this one so they end up
pollinating the color of those flowers
that that didn't emerge randomly that's
the reason that exists is because it was
selected for it did it did emerge
randomly but it was selected to stay and
to accumulate in its ability to transmit
that color to further and further
distances
by making that color brighter and
brighter because it was increasing that
plant's ability to survive and reproduce
so there's real signaling happening here
that's why those flowers exist they are
signaling structures one of the things
i've noticed with people that are
skeptical of evolution is they tend to
think that you would need the new
information to be something
very very dramatic
and then it gets selected to stay right
whereas actually it only needs to be
very very subtle and then you just get
like an evolutionary arms race
until you get something that's very very
complex and i found that when i was
learning evolution when i was when i was
younger that was one of the harder
things to get my head around and it took
like a few core examples to to figure
out how that works to get my head around
it but um i wanted to emphasize that and
a couple other things here and that is
that in biology is a um is a symbol and
a signal synonymous or are they
different in biology we use the term
signal where
in semiotics you might call it a symbol
there's actually a bunch of different
words for it we are cue detecting
entities like i can detect when
like my wife gets home from work like
she's not telling me necessarily that
she got home from work but i hear her
open the door and she comes into the
house right yeah so and i'm just picking
up on cues
my dogs can pick up on cues too like if
we start packing bags for vacation they
get super upset because they know what's
coming they know that we're going to
leave them at someone else's house and
they're not going to see us for a while
so they say that that's a cue because
that is that it's not something you're
in yeah because you're so like you're
not intending to convey that information
to your dogs but they pick up that cue
and like you haven't evolved to
communicate that and you're not
deliberately trying to communicate like
this there's no you're not trying to
communicate that at all but that's what
what the dogs will pick up so it's a cue
whereas a signal would be something that
is it's deliberate in the definition of
it being selected for like it it's got
like a a purpose in that sense or um
just deliberate in a conscious sense if
you're like talking about languages such
as english and things like that yeah the
word deliberate is something that a lot
of people don't really like to use
signaling
because i mean you could say that the
flower is deliberately broadcasting a
message to pollinators but it's a little
bit weird to say that it's doing that
deliberately because it doesn't have a
brain and we
we
want to associate intentions with brains
because that's
maybe because because we're selfish and
we like to think that we're special but
the plant obviously doesn't have a brain
you can definitely say that it's
actively transmitting this signal and
that it evolved to do that there's this
adaptive definition of signaling in
biology in order for it to be called a
signal both of the players in the
communication have to be benefiting
evolutionarily for participating in the
communication if the sender only
benefits and the receiver it changes its
behavior but then hurts itself by doing
so we call that coercion we don't even
call that signaling okay so that there
is a flower that's coercive it pretends
it sends out sex hormones yes it sends a
sex hormone so a bee will come hump it
it doesn't get any nectar nothing it
just
it thinks that it's mating with a female
that's not called signaling that's
called coercion so would coercion also
count as these bright frogs you know
which
they essentially want to get eaten so
that they kill crim kill the
predators in the area due to them being
poisonous thus allowing the rest of the
frogs to survive would that counters
there's a misunderstanding there on how
how we think that evolves that might be
too far of a tangent we think that in
most cases what's happening is an animal
will evolve a toxin so it does make
predators sick the predator is maybe not
dying but it's like
i do not want to eat that again
they just have a horrible time and so
they're remembering something
that they noticed about the animal and
if it was a slight red tint or something
they're going to remember that and
they're going to be super cautious for
anything with a red tint and what that
does is once you have enough predators
that are scared of a red tint now there
is selection pressure to be red
and if you're red you don't get eaten
and the more red you are the less often
you get confused for something that's
food and the less often you die so you
have this new selection pressure to
become bright red it requires enough of
the predators to either have learned
that you're not good to eat or to have
evolved a phobia of you it's way slower
but you can evolve a phobia as well as
learn to be afraid of a certain cue in
most cases we think that this starts out
as a cue detection on the predator side
and then the prey item ends up adapting
evolving and it really is a signal
because
the prey item doesn't want to get eaten
and the predator doesn't want to eat a
toxic prey item so it's actually that is
a signal both organisms are benefiting
in that communication
there are other ways that that can
evolve that we can imagine that can
evolve and it's probably evolved in
different ways in different times but
it's not coercive because both of them
are benefiting
both of them have an evolutionary
benefit for not engaging in that fight
yeah so
communication systems they're everywhere
in nature and i'll i'll even show more
of those i'll do a deep dive into that
here in a minute but
the other point that i want to make is
the communication systems can emerge
naturally thinking minds are not
required to design them and this is very
counterintuitive at first but it becomes
really clear when you when you look at
all the research that's been done on
this here we have some e coli and e coli
have quite complex communication systems
they coordinate their behaviors with
each other and these communication
molecules these symbols that they
excrete and detect from each other these
evolved under selection pressure to
cooperate that's how this communication
system emerged within bacteria and the
third thing that i want to drive home is
that the genetic code really is a simple
language it has these linguistic
properties
compared to english it's incredibly
simple some linguists will be like okay
i'm okay with you calling it a language
if you make sure to point out that it's
extremely simple compared to english
some linguists might say that
as you know linguists study human
language some of them might say uh i'd
rather you just say that it has
linguistic properties
but
it really does have linguistic
properties and more specifically the
genetic code is a signal-based
communication system
you actually had a definition of
language in your video there's three
issues that i have with the statement
you say that language is the exchange of
information from one entity to another
through mutually understood signs and
dna my friends isn't that
of course i have i take issue with the
fact that you say it isn't that because
i say it is
i also take slight issue with saying dna
here because it's actually the genetic
code dna is one component in this system
there's multiple parts that are actually
not dna to say that dna is the language
is like saying that mouth noises are
english it's um
people say it all the time they say that
dna is code or dna is language and i get
what they're saying i don't take major
issue with it but it is it's a little
bit weird to say and then you said
mutually understood signs here again
because
a cell doesn't have a brain and
understood is something that we
associate with brains i would change it
to just say that
there are established signs
so they've they've been established in
advance that's what allows communication
to happen yeah i would i would i'm happy
to say that that's i think that's one of
the biggest if not the biggest blunder i
think i made in the video um so yeah
fair enough man
fair play so we do have two entities
here that are communicating with each
other the sending entity is the genome
so that's where the dna is that the
actual message is messenger rna so it's
a protein-coding chain of rna and the
the actual symbols in that are what we
call codons and i'll talk about what
codons are later
the interpreting entity the thing that
does the interpretation is the ribosome
and the meaning of a particular message
is a finished protein so a specific type
of protein
the genome and the ribosome are
communicating with each other and what
are they communicating about they're
communicating about proteins they're
trying to build these proteins so let's
dive in here to the meat and potatoes of
the this this first claim that symbol or
signal based languages these
communication systems they're everywhere
in biology thinking minds are not
required to operate them
and first a little jargon site we kind
of covered some of this already but
there's a bunch of different fields that
deal with languages and codes and they
define terms slightly differently and
for important reasons based on important
arguments that happened in those fields
in the past linguists study human
languages that's their focus so when
there's anything simpler than human
languages that people want to talk about
as language they'll get a little bit
agitated like if you say that coco the
gorilla is using language they're like
okay coco the gorilla was using a really
simplified version of sign language but
most of the syntax that we have in sign
language she completely didn't
understand she ignored i don't want to
call that human language for sure yeah
she was definitely using
symbols though a linguistic property
yeah computer scientists they study
machine and programming languages some
of them are as complex as english i
would say
probably get up there then you have
biologists and ethologists of the famous
ethologists would be jane goodall
richard dawkins they studied signaling
in animals that was the a lot of people
don't know this that was actually
dawkins things he studied signaling he
actually made really big contributions
to the the field of animal signaling did
his um selfish gene make um
like how does signaling work with the
selfish gene you know you got like bees
which uh they're not trying to preserve
themselves as in an individual they're
trying to preserve their hive because
the hive has their dna and so you have
this evolutionary pressure to be able to
you know basically kill themselves in
order to preserve their own genes which
is in their kin is i i i would imagine
signaling has something it can be put
into
uh the the language that's that's
happening there when a b is enraged one
of the things that causes a b to get
enraged is
the ripping a part of another b if you
injure another b there are molecules
that are sent out from that bee's body
that stimulates a rage response and
other bees it's a very automatic thing
they've evolved to do that so it is
signaling they're receiving a signal
that there's been a death and it causes
them to go into
fight mode so
yeah it does fit that way
richard dawkins he was mainly studying
signals and animals i think he mostly
focused on birds i want to say he didn't
really talk about that much in like the
selfish gene the selfish gene was just
him summarizing other people's work
basically but his actual contributions
to the primary scientific literature a
lot of it was in signaling how it is
that communication happens between
animals so that is that is a very
important field of biology it's become a
very important field of biology
and they define terms very specifically
we already mentioned how before we
consider the signal has to be shown to
be adapted for both the sender and the
receiver otherwise we call it a queue or
we call it a coercion
and then you have semioticians so
semiotics this is the study of the
meaning of signs and they'll study
man-made signs that you'd have in in
language human languages they'll study
you know signaling in animals anything
it doesn't matter
they're really interested in the
meanings of signs they actually don't
use the word language very much they
they talk about codes so they would they
would actually consider english to be a
code a really complex coding system
you've got encoding and decoding
so
of course there's ways to make an
argument that the genetic code is not
language there's so many different
definitions of language to choose from
you're guaranteed to find one sure
this is it yeah i was like with those
four that you've got there
am i right in saying that the first two
uh presuppose in an intelligent creator
or at least a mind that's part of the
process so you've got like human
languages and like these things have
evolved where i'm using words that
you're processing in your brain right
right i'm intelligently trying to give
it to you and you are intelligently
interpreting it and then when it comes
to computers
although you can set up an algorithm and
you can have it so it's running without
any kind of intelligent input
what's interesting here is that you do
need well you don't i don't know if you
need maybe you can tell me if i'm wrong
here like this would be good but it
seems to me that you need the initial
state to be set up by someone that knows
what they're doing which is kind of like
the argument that that's being put
across now right they think that that's
the equivalent of what's happened with
dna and that for some reason they think
that an all-powerful all-loving god has
selected for dna which absolutely ends
up in with really nasty mistakes like
evolution is a wonderful process and
everything but it is disgustingly brutal
i think sam harris was saying that
evolution if it was designed by god it
is a system that would embarrass
a psychopath
in every single way it's an incredibly
nasty process so yeah yeah so these
first two linguists are studying human
language the interesting thing about
human language is that it actually
wasn't invented by anybody it was
languages emerge within a culture there
was no one who sat down and designed
english
that never happened i guess one of the
arguments that you got most in trouble
for on your on your videos was um
there's this big debate right now we
have a splitting of words right now
between sex and gender
we're seeing the evolution of english
language right before our very eyes with
this fight that's going on between how
should we define male and female man and
woman that
it's super interesting from an
evolutionary perspective from a linguist
perspective like we're watching language
change right before our very eyes and
it's super it's super cool i think
yeah and definitely in this case it's
it's there's a lot of kicking screaming
as it's happening like people don't want
the language to change
it is amazing isn't it it's like you
look at um words such as awesome and
because it's not imbued in a political
context it just changes regularly right
right um you know we say oh that's
terrible we mean it's good so it's like
these words have just completely went
from top to bottom
but because as you were saying like man
and woman is in a political landscape
you've got it so that there's sophistry
and rhetoric applied so that one side
will just go no it must be defined as a
woman is a biological female and then
you've got the other side saying if you
don't agree with my definition you're
automatically bigoted and it's amazing
as you said it is amazing as a biologist
or a sociologist it must be a very
interesting thing to uh to be watching
it's amazing how just language
well it just is the beyond endless so
many arguments in philosophy and science
ethics
politics and um
as we said we're focusing a lot on the
definition of
language itself
it really does illustrate that point
human language has definitely emerged
and we use brains to process them
machine languages you can find the
person a lot of them are still alive
that actually invented specific machine
languages or programming languages like
the guy who invented javascript for
example which is a programming language
he's still around you can go talk to him
and buy him coffee if you want so
creationists might see that i'm like oh
well
this you can go meet the guy he's he's
he's the modern person and the the
original person was jesus or whatever so
you gotta get the uh the jesus
javascript argument
yeah
yeah so
it makes sense that people are trying to
make this argument or that this thought
occurs to them right yeah yeah
absolutely i actually worked with the
linguist to come up with this kind of
all-encompassing definition for language
code communication system
shout out to stefan hurtubise he's the
linguist out in montreal that helped me
on this so a language is a set of
symbols
their meanings
and syntax rules allowing one entity to
transmit messages to another and
according to him he said any linguist
would see that and be like okay yeah
that's good
they might want to specify that
it doesn't really count as language
unless a human is speaking it but he
said that's you know
if they understand you're going for a
general thing that yes they're going to
be perfectly happy with this and someone
who designed programming languages or
machine languages would also be happy
with this because when i press a key on
my keyboard my keyboard is transmitting
a message to my computer that my
computer is interpreting there is a
sender and a receiver there is a set of
symbols which in this case is binary
we're covering all the bases here
and this really does cover what's
special about the genetic code is the
genetic code is this as well and then a
symbol
in some fields is called a signal or a
sign or a code point or a codon this is
a thing which arbitrarily represents
another thing within a specific language
but is not
that thing i am cool with these i've
i have been calmly educated and i am uh
i'm very very grateful on this fact no
seriously i i'm cool
another way to think of a signal or a
symbol
is like why like what's the point of
encoding something into some sort of a
signal a signal is any easily
transmittable thing so a sound or a
color or a gesture or a molecule or an
electric pulse in the case of a computer
which represents another thing that
cannot be transmitted as efficiently so
if we just look at english
in the english language i'm the sender
you're the receiver the word the symbol
that i'm using here is apple that is a
physical thing i'm sending a sound
vibration to you which is a physical
thing it's easier for me to transmit
that sound vibration than to actually
transmit an apple to you right
yep
but you interpret that as meaning
an apple
one of the neat properties about
language and this is also true of the
genetic code is that it's possible that
you don't speak the same language as me
and so when i try to communicate with
you there's going to be miscommunication
if i say poem which is french for apple
and you don't speak french yeah
communication is failed
and this is a very special property of
languages we can find this in the
genetic code as well
so how does that relate to cues
in a queue the sender isn't
trying to communicate with the receiver
the sender is just going about his daily
business i used to be in boy scouts
growing up and we were camping in an
area that had black bears and black
bears will run away from humans they're
scared of humans
but if you surprise one it'll kill you
right because
if it doesn't notice you and all of a
sudden you're in its face it's it'll
fight you if you're walking
it's going to hear your footsteps and
run away that's cue detection right it's
detecting transmissions that you're
making but you're not making those
transmissions so that the bearer will
hear it we were taught that we should be
loud when we're walking through the
woods and talk loudly and if we're not
talking we should sing a song or hum a
song
that way the bear will be sure to hear
us and make sure to run away way before
we come in contact with it
we were told to to transform our q into
a signal to actively magnify it we knew
how this bear would respond and so
we magnified our q
by magnifying that q we turned it into a
signal does that make sense yeah
absolutely yes great example
okay so
everybody pretty much gets human
language right there's there's no
no one's confused that english is a
language no one's confused it french as
a language the wolf pheromone signaling
system is actually a communication
system so a female wolf when she's an
estrus she'll produce this molecule in
her urine it's methylp
hydroxyben benzoate benzoate
and that molecule is unique to wolves
and it's unique to wolves that are in
estrus and it's excreted into their
urine and if a male wolf picks that up
they interpret that meaning as ah
there's mating to be had here
and the reason that we say that that is
a signal not just a cue
is that if you watch a female wolf it
doesn't just happen to be a byproduct
that her body makes when she's an estrus
she's actively transmitting she marks
all over the place and she marks as high
as possible on trees and so on so that
that signal gets wafted as far and as
wide as possible she's actively
transmitting that there are also other
reasons to suspect that this isn't just
an accidental byproduct of being an
estrus this molecule
it's actually
an evolved signal because
if you look at closely related species
they have
slight tweaks to these these molecules
or at least to the concentrations of
them that are produced that makes it so
that there's not confusion between
species so if a fox gets this same woof
of the same urine he's not going to be
confused and think that there's a mate
he's just not going to know what it is
it's not going to make any sense to them
there is an evolved signaling system
that's happened here other wolves
understand it they've evolved to
understand it even other canids don't
understand that foxes don't understand
the wolf's mating signals in their urine
this is quite obviously a signal and
with her actively doing it um sorry to
interrupt but with her actively doing it
that's not necessarily emphasizing that
she's conscious of doing it it's just
it's just a process for her
yeah she might be we don't know i mean
we don't know how much of her brain is
involved in this i mean obviously she
doesn't know the chemical structure of
the thing that she's emitting in her
urine and you just you could always just
extract this out right so insects
communicate with pheromones a lot
and i would presume that they probably
don't have consciousness so you know you
would but it's still a signal for the
reasons that you put out before like
when the b
you know there's a signal that's
transmitted every you can't be
deliberately sending out a sign because
it's dead you know with the b examples
but it's still a signal
yeah you have these these systems and
again the the neat property of them
one neat thing to point out is that if
you don't speak the language there's no
communication that happens so if the
interpreter doesn't understand that
language there's no communication and i
say understand in a general sense so you
don't need a brain necessarily but if
you're if you're not set up if the
signal hasn't been established for you
there's no communication
another one that's definitely doesn't
use a brain is the human endocrine
system so
testicles produce testosterone
and that gets sent all through the
bloodstream and there's a bunch of cells
that have testosterone receptors we call
them androgen receptors
and when those receptors which are very
special proteins when they bump into a
testosterone molecule they bind to it it
changes their shape they're able to
enter the nucleus of the cell and then
bind to it genes specific genes and it's
it's different depending on the cell
type which ones are available
and then those genes will cause the cell
to behave differently
and so here we have the your testicles
are talking to your face
you're sending messages to your face if
there's testosterone and if you have the
androgen receptors in your face you can
grow a beard so that's the meanings like
grow a beard
it's kind of funny like a lot of a lot
of us then shave them afterwards but and
also i should point out that some
lineages actually can't grow beards
because they don't have those androgen
receptors in the face aren't there a lot
of people will talk about like native
americans either really thin beards or
sometimes no beards at all and it's
because they don't have they haven't
evolved this
the androgen receptors in the face in
the same pattern that europeans do they
don't grow the same types of beards
so considering that we are descended
from you know other other apes and you
know chimpanzees mammals etc well we are
a mammal
would it be actually that they've had a
selection process to no longer grow on
the face just as every humans basically
had a selection not to grow it you know
near the eyes and stuff like is it is it
that way round it's actually not clear i
don't know that lineage specific beard
patterns have been studied all that well
it would be super interesting though
because
i think it's super interesting i mean
darwin actually spent a lot of time
speculating about why we have beards he
thinks it was sexual selection yeah i
mean everyone has a little bit of facial
hair females tend not to have it and
males tend to have it because because
it's testosterone that's the signal for
it
there are other ways to stimulate hair
growth too aside from testosterone but
talking of interesting things
one um
one of the ways that the word woman has
been
one of the reasons it's being redefined
relates to actually something similar to
this and that is that if you have a
condition called complete androgen
insensitivity syndrome yes it means that
your body can't synthesize the
testosterone
and consequently you won't grow like the
beard even if you do have it in in you
okay super small correction people with
androgen and sensitivity syndrome
actually they can produce testosterone
they just can't receive it so it's like
i'm speaking french just fine but you
don't speak french and so there's
miscommunication my apologies no thank
you for correcting me so you have you
have that condition and it's amazing
that males
present completely as females right
because they grow breasts they grow they
don't grow as tall they get wide hips
like for most of human history males
were
identified uh that had this condition as
woman and it's like that's one of the
arguments that's been put through
to say actually we're wrong on the way
that we're looking at
man and woman
similar to how when we found the um
what's that mammal that has no it just
absolutely messes up everything the
platypus right you find a platypus and
you go all right now we have to go look
at our definitions again because this
changes things up
it just reminded me of that and i
thought i'd uh check it on there since
you're mentioning there's actually so
many weird exceptions for
sex differences among animals that
evolutionary biologists
try to define male and female by what
type of gamete you produce so if you
produce egg cells they want to say that
you're female if you use sperm cells
they want to say that you're male but
they're not doing that in a medical
sense for humans they're doing it for
all of biology because there's so many
different organisms that are
hermaphroditic for example they produce
egg cells and sperm cells
in the human case because we're not
trying to find a general rule for all
organisms
it's perfectly reasonable that we have
much more nuance when we're talking
about humans so someone with androgen
insensitivity they actually produce
sperm cells they don't produce egg cells
yeah and it's like if you define that by
if you define sex by gamete type which
has been what i've understood biologists
tend to do
spoken to a few because of
the background that i had
if you define it by gammy type then in
that case they are male and off but it
just shows how how culture had the wrong
idea of thinking that a man necessarily
means male it's like no man doesn't
necessarily mean that it's
just interesting stuff another little
editor's note here this picture which i
grabbed from wikipedia is of a bunch of
women with androgen and sensitivity
syndrome so actually some of them are
intersex in other ways but so these
women have xy chromosomes they can
produce sperm well they can sort of
produce sperm the sperm aren't actually
viable in people with complete androgen
insensitivity but obviously for a lot of
people it seems counterintuitive to
consider these people men
now here on the right i've got blurred
out a photo right now i'm going to show
it to you if you are uncomfortable with
nudity i suggest that you pause this
video
go talk to a psychologist or something
because uh it's just the human body
this woman is actually she produces
sperm she is xy this is what complete
androgen insensitivity syndrome looks
like not only would you not know that
she's according to some definitions a
male in many cases she wouldn't know
and you know she might get married and
have a heterosexual relationship with a
man and everything totally fine except
for that she would be infertile it's a
pretty rare condition but it's not some
sort of crazy extremist anti-science
statement to say that the definition
that evolutionary biologists use for
male and female it honestly doesn't
capture all the things that most folks
care about when they talk about men
women males and females
so the interesting thing about these
signals here is that
the sender can miscommunicate so you
could have a disorder where you're not
producing testosterone appropriately
and that can cause men to start growing
breasts for example
or you can have the interpreter can can
have an error so an androgen
insensitivity the interpreter is got a
mutation that breaks it it can't really
grab on to testosterone properly and so
the other property of languages is you
can have miscommunication from the
sender and from the receiver and you can
also have interference where the actual
signal can get intercepted by
something in between two all of these
beautiful linguistic properties exist in
the endocrine system they exist in these
pheromone systems and so on again if
there's hair follicles cells without
androgen receptors that testosterone
enters the cell and it's just it's just
some noise in the cell it does it means
nothing
anything can be used as a symbol in a
communication system we talked about
urinating already
it can be tactile signals visual
chemical audible whatever so this dog is
actively communicating this is he's not
just peeing he's peeing as high as he
can he's trying to announce his presence
right
the flower is using uh visual signals to
communicate they've also got a bunch of
chemical signals fragrances that they're
emitting as well these ants are using
tactile and chemical signaling they can
sense molecules on each other and
they're also just touching each other in
the right ways so they know that they're
the same species and they're they might
be actually sending other information
here too like where to go
and find food and so on signalling can
happen between members of the same
species this i think this group is
called their butterfly fish and they're
actually signaling what species they are
to other butterfly fish because they eat
very specific types of food and so if
there's more than one of the same type
of butterfly fish on the same chunk of
rock they're going to end up fighting so
this is basically advertisement if
you're one of me don't come here
i will fight you
so they can see this from a long
distance away and they know i'm not
going to bother risking my life to swim
from this area all the way to that area
in this the open water to just go fight
some dude that's already there so
there's they're signaling with these
colors we can see this by looking at the
color differences between different
species and then using genetics to see
how closely related they are how
distantly related they are and we find
that it's being in direct proximity to
someone who's actually not a threat that
triggers natural selection to start
selecting for a difference in coloration
patterns so you get this crazy rainbow
of of colors from species to species
they're signaling yeah it's absolutely
amazing
it's uh do you know if their color at
all comes from their food i think um
with like bioluminescence
some creatures have got that because
they eat food that is bio luminescent in
this case i don't think that's i i'm
pretty sure they're i could be wrong
there's always individual little
exceptions but yeah these pigments that
they're making i believe they synthesize
themselves
basically everything that makes you go
whoa when you're outside that's a signal
like that the song of a bird the color
crazy color of a fish those are signals
we just don't understand what they mean
so they look crazy and beautiful to us
the feathers of a peacock it's signaling
to females that it's
it's healthy enough to grow this crazy
thing
and it also uses this to threaten
predators like a predator comes to it
it's got all these eyes that are staring
at the predators like what the heck is
this
it's actually a misnomer to say that
this just evolved to impress females
here we have what's called starting a
lot of antelope species will do this
they will jump vertically really high
when they see a predator and this is
signaling a couple things it's still
like the predator now knows that it's
been spotted because they do this when
when there's a predator around so it's
like crap if i was if i needed to
surprise this animal to catch it that's
my cover's blown yeah we think that this
evolved because
when
you're running in a herd away from a
predator if a predator is chasing an
entire herd the herd runs slower than
individuals can
because just because there's a bunch of
animals trying to coordinate their
efforts if you're in the end of that and
there's a predator right behind you you
can jump vertically straight up and show
that predator how strong you are so it's
like if he singles you out and gets you
on a one-on-one chase
he's probably not going to win so you're
able to show how strong you are by
jumping straight up in the air even
though you can't move fast forward right
and so the predator benefits from this
he doesn't want to chase the happiest
healthiest individual he wants to get
the one that's gonna be easy dinner
right so basically by jumping straight
up it's saying don't eat me eat the
other one
and it's actually a benefit for both the
sender and the receiver which is the
predator in this case it's not a benefit
to the other guy that gets
that gets eaten but
so this is a form of signaling between
predator and prey that happens and then
we have signaling that happens between
mutual symbionts this is a gobi and a
shrimp the shrimp is really good at
digging and the gobi is really good at
spotting food sources and so the the
gobi will guide the shrimp to food
and the shrimp will maintain the lodge
that they both live in and they have
these really complex
systems of the way he twitches his tail
they definitely have a complex signaling
system between them ah to me see that
reminds me of um i think it's there's a
certain tribe in africa that they have
like a similar relationship with birds
where the birds
will
they're like they're like cool out with
whistles and then the birds will show
them where there's honey right and then
after they go to the tree and they get
stung like hell getting this honey out
they break off a bit and give it to the
bird right and you've just got this
relationship and you know i don't know
how long that's lasted but that's just
like it reminds me of what you're
showing there it's
you know this thing is is probably not
as rare as you might think
right
language can vary in complexity
from a single word which you wouldn't
really want to call it a language you
know it's just a signal
too many signals the signaling that
happens between plants and pollinators
is actually pretty complex a flower will
signal when it has nectar it'll signal
when it's already been pollinated it
doesn't want pollinators to bother it
anymore there's some really complex
signaling happening between flowers
and pollinators and we think that
flowers they're aware not aware mentally
but they change physiologically when
they sense the vibration of a bee's
wings they can start generating more
nectar if they didn't have very much and
then here we have this red frog it's a
one word signaling system
it's basically saying like i'm toxic
don't mess with me it's going to be bad
for you
we talked about how that could evolve
you know funny enough that looks like um
uh some of the uh fruit you can get in
england where it's like even as a kid
i'd look at it and i'd go i don't want
that even though i'd go eat the
blackberries i'd look at the red ones
and i'd go that's not going to go down
well it turns out it's very poisonous to
us good that i don't go for it but you
can tell that that was in me
installed if i was going to go jordan
peterson on you i'd be like oh we got
the motif of the redness and it's uh
that's why the devil is red that's you
know
yeah i mean there might be instinctual
reasons why we hate certain colors be i
mean we know that this is the case in
animals like they're instinctually
afraid of certain colors
probably in humans it's a lot more
cultural than instinctual because we've
lived in a lot of different environments
and they've been exposed to a lot of
different dangers and a lot of different
signaling systems what happens is you'll
you'll find that different colors are
warning systems in different ecosystems
because that's how it's evolved there
you can have yellows or a lot of times
warning signals
and blues and then reds
basically anything that's super obvious
to see most predators are going to be
cautious like why why are you making
yourself so obvious this is weird and
part of that's learned and part of its
instinctual for most predators yeah like
the i mean yes so like the argument of
how much of it is cultural how much of
it is natural is obviously a very
difficult one to navigate but one thing
that's really fascinated me is there's a
lot of sociological and this is a bit of
a tangent but there's a lot of
sociological work that relates to um
snakes and humans relationship to snakes
and it's like why do snakes keep keep
coming up in our stories to do with
religion right so you've got genesis and
you've got it you know why why is the
devil a snake why not why not a bee
right i mean more people in england die
from bee stings every year than they do
snakes like objectively empirically bees
are a worse enemy than snakes but but
it's not a b wouldn't make sense in that
story whereas a snake has been
a very serious predator to mammals for a
very very long time and so it makes
sense why it keeps coming up but my
favorite instance of that was
in norse mythology or norse religion you
know to me that they're largely the same
thing it's amazing that their leviathan
which is the world serpent is a snake
and it's like really an ectophermic
species happens to be the leviathan in
this frozen wasteland
yeah yeah it's funny like but maybe not
a coincidence if you take seriously that
maybe these things are etched in us
oh yeah yeah there we do know that
humans have an instinctually fast
response so we can spot snakes faster
than almost anything else yeah i think
we can spot an angry human face faster
than a snake um in these psychology
tests but other than that like snake is
number one we can spot a snake
they'll flash pictures in front of you
and you say when you found the organism
we spot snakes immediately and the same
is true with with monkeys they can do
these weird tests where they're actually
putting probes in the brain which is
messed up but for science i don't think
it's even worth knowing what they
learned from this but they put probes
and monkey brains and they would do the
same thing so you can actually see when
it's
when it's alarmed yeah and same with
snakes you can drop a cucumber you drop
a cucumber near a snake it is going to
go mental
uh in most cases a cucumber near a snake
oh sorry this is a snake a cute yeah you
put it on your snake it's not going to
do anything sorry cats that's the one
yeah if you put a cucumber or a cat it's
gonna it's gonna peg it
yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting i'm
curious what the cucumber thing is if
you put anything really weird behind a
cat would it do that or is it
specifically the cucumber but hey john
it's all for science yeah yeah
basically we can see that for signal
based communication to occur the sender
must actively encode information into a
transmittable form so a signal that the
receiver is likely to decode or
interpret and if the receiver interprets
that signal correctly we say that
communication has occurred biologists
would bump that one more degree of
complexity and say that both of them
have on average benefit from the
communication it has to be in their
selective advantage to participate in
this before we actually call it
communication otherwise we might call it
coercion right
one organism is coercing another to do
something that it
shouldn't be doing for its own
well-being
that is communication a thinking mind is
not required for that to happen you can
have encoded information you can have
that decoded a thinking mind is not
required to encode and decode a message
here we have some human made languages
and some non-human languages you've got
english you've got morse code on the
human side you've got ascii code so you
know binary that represents the english
alphabet you've got javascript you've
got c plus plus you've got musical
notation these are all things we can
talk about as human invented signaling
systems or languages and then on the
non-human side you've got things like
the pheromone signaling and dogs plant
pollinator signaling quorum sensing and
bacteria the plant mycorrhizal signaling
so this is between plants and fungi they
do a lot of communicating between each
other they have a symbiotic relationship
and then the endocrine system so the
hormone system and the genetic code
some of these use brains some of them do
not when we're talking about dogs and
the pheromone signaling system you can
actually argue it's not really they're
not using their mind to interpret that
so much as their instincts but again
that's that's what we think and then
with the plant you've got a bee which
can actually figure things out and do
some some processing with its brain to
understand what the what it should be
doing with this plant but the plant
certainly doesn't have a brain
simple languages are everywhere in
biology
and we're cool with that right
absolutely yeah all right so
communication systems can emerge
naturally thinking minds are not
required to design them this i think is
going to be news to a lot of people
especially to creationists who haven't
thought about this and the problems
there they see it's it's a it's an
appropriate problem to see is that
before communication works the meaning
of each symbol must be established the
sender and the receiver have to have
that meaning established so how then do
languages emerge how is each symbol's
meaning established this isn't just a
puzzling question for
the endocrine system
or the genetic code this is a puzzling
system for english like like we said no
one sat down and invented english how do
we decide what words mean you know
and how do we decide to change that well
in biology in signaling we learned that
signals come from cues they start out as
queues my dog and i have a bunch of
signals that we use to communicate with
each other
and a lot of them started out as cues so
we are both thinking animals and we're
establishing these the the meanings of
these cues
with our brains and not only has she
established a bunch of signals with me
she's established a bunch of signals
with our other dog they actually
communicate quite a bit i could spend a
bunch of time studying how they
communicate with each other but there's
there's a really interesting signal that
developed between zoe and i when my wife
and i first moved in together these dogs
were hers with me moving in here just
stirring things up a lot
like we would sometimes forget to make
sure the dog's water bowl was full and
i'm i'm working from home so i'm always
here and right next to my office is the
bathtub and so zoe would jump in the
bathtub when she was thirsty and lick
the water off of the bottom of the
bathtub well when i realized that i
panicked like oh my gosh i'm a i'm a
horrible human like
my dog doesn't have water
so the first time i noticed her doing
that i freaked out and i went and i gave
her food and water and treats and
attention it was like the best thing
ever for her she's like wow
for some reason this guy loves it when i
jump in the bathtub
you know
so
so
when i do this he does everything i want
she started doing it all the time and uh
she she realized she didn't it's hard
for her because she's a little tiny dog
to jump in the bathtub it's easy for her
to just put her paws on it and kind of
ding around on it if i just hear her
claws on the side of the bat that might
come just as quickly and so she
eventually stopped jumping in the tub
and would just smack the the side of the
of the bathtub and then i'd get up and
i'd come and give her
rewards
eventually she stopped doing it when she
needed water she'd just do it when she
wanted attention and the signal actually
broke down because i got better at
remembering to give her water
and she kept exploiting this situation
and so the signal eventually broke down
and she no longer does it but for a
while we had this signal going where she
would just go into the bathroom she
wouldn't go to me she would go into the
bathroom and make noise on the bathtub
and i would come running so we had an
active signal between us yeah
it's i mean that's brilliant i've got a
bearded dragon wonderful creature
incredibly i don't know how they survive
they don't seem smart but
you know if you judge a fish by how well
it can climb a tree then that's probably
what i'm doing right just just in
relation to that uh she will headbutt
the glass when she wants to come out
very simple potentially there's a bit of
you know pavillonian conditioning there
where she's going that is her way to
communicate she knows that when she does
that i'm going to let her out so that
she can scat all over the floor um so
yeah
if you think about what's happening here
it's the same as training i don't know
if you ever trained a dog before but i
gave zoey a bunch of rewards for doing a
particular behavior that's exactly the
same as giving her a treat for laying
down or rolling over the only real
difference here is that she was an
active part in coming up with that
signal too the queue is turned into a
signal when you have two organisms with
thinking minds that are motivated to
cooperate
they can transform cues into signals and
this is the same like you can teach your
dog what the word sit means because the
dog wants to cooperate to get that food
from you when there's motivation to
cooperate cues turn into signals
that happens
that is natural
important to really drive this home that
a q it's a passive transmission a signal
is an active transmission and then if
you got one or more established signals
you have a communication system you
could call it a language it's got it's
got linguistic properties
an example of a queue if a male is in
the house and they leave the seat up
they weren't necessarily trying to
announce that hey a male is here
they probably just forgot to put the
seat down after they peed
so that's just a cue
but this dog is actually transmitting
hey a male is here
you know it's that is an active signal
that that dog is transmitting i mean i
suppose a male might do this on purpose
too leave the seat up yeah
well we've got like all the reason to
think that the dog is conscious but is
it conscious of that or is it not and if
it's not conscious of that then
is it a cue right or or how does it
relate to q because
yeah it's it's interesting it seems to
be the intention here i mean maybe you
can help me out there what what role
does intention play in making a cue a
signal intention doesn't have to be a
part of it at all it's it kind of it
feels like we want to say intention
because we have a dog and the dog has a
brain
if if we're saying that intentions come
from minds attention doesn't have to be
here at all what has to be here is that
it is an adaptation the dog has evolved
to magnify this cue oh yeah and because
the dog has evolved under selection
pressure to magnify this cue we say that
it is now a signal and i understand that
that can get tricky because like how do
you know that it evolved to do that
there are way i mean we know that the
dogs benefit from this communication
it's obvious that they benefit from it
it's how they find mates
and
that so obviously mating is how you win
the evolutionary game yeah whereas
leaving the toilet seat up is actually
probably a way not to uh
like
i don't know many people at all that
appreciate it
right right
so any queue can eventually become a
signal if it ends up benefiting i have a
twin brother and we actually had a
little language that we had before we
learned english i was talking about this
with my dad i was like do you think that
we actually developed parts of that
completely uniquely or do you think it
was all modified english he says i think
a lot of it was you couldn't say a word
right and then it would just evolve out
of control and you're saying something
that sounds nothing like the word but in
some cases it might have been i'm
speaking gibberish because that's what
babies do and my brother's listening to
me and then we we see something that we
both like so we see a cat or something
and then he would interpret whatever
noise that i just made as the happy
noise
signaling can happen between animals
humans need not apply this is a coyote
signaling to a badger that he wants to
go on a hunt it really is cool coyotes
and badgers make these partnerships all
over north america this is super common
the coyotes usually initiate it coyotes
are way better at catching ground
squirrels and so on if a badger is
helping and actually badgers are better
at catching him if coyote is helping but
it's more beneficial for the coyotes so
you almost always see the coyote
initiating these relationships wow
that's that's incredible that's so cool
yeah
and the badger will bail on him as soon
as he's mating so yeah
sorry the wife ain't letting me go on a
hunting trip with you anymore
it's kind of funny
so how do encoding decoding rules evolve
that's the big question right like we
know how they emerge with animals with
thinking minds how do they evolve and
there's a bunch of them we see them
everywhere in nature flowers are an
example that i've talked about earlier
that really complex seedling that's
happening
and different flowers actually have
signals that are species specific
they're they're trying to get specific
types of pollinators to to visit them
there's exclusion and different
languages you could say signaling
systems
that have emerged between flowers and
pollinators it's like some of them have
evolved basically only to get
hummingbirds if they're not mistaken
right right yeah and they're trying to
exclude other things and and other
things through experience like okay i
keep going to this flower it's a bright
color but it where's the nectar i can't
get to it
and so the you know after having that
interaction a couple times they'd
like screw this thing it's not good so
they'll go look for another one so
angiosperms are these flowering plants
and this is kind of a tangent here but
every valentine's day the flower is
actually the plant's genitals and so i
like to send out this meme it's a token
of my affection please accept the spokay
of severed angiosperm genitals
all right i'm stealing that that's
brilliant yeah we're we're brutal we're
we are savage see like i've always
flowers have never made much sense to me
i'm just thinking
we
here you go i've ended the lives of
several beautiful things
to show you that i care and it's like
what
what the hell is this but i actually
think that what you've got there is
better that's beautiful they can usually
regrow their genitals okay it's not
necessarily fatal to castrate a flower
i don't know
but yeah the casual plant yeah it is
funny it's hilarious and we we put our
face in them you know like
well the other thing is that
they've you know they put the food on
their genitals for uh
for other animals to come and eat from
yeah yeah so i really if someone had
just tuned in now that would be
that'd be a great time
right
so gymnosperms or sometimes called
gynosperms they are non-flowering plants
they have the they have pine cones and
so on instead and they normally they're
pollinated by just the wind a lot of
their species are if you look at what
they're doing here they're producing all
sorts of pollen so the psychic plant is
a very really common gem to sperm that a
lot of people are aware of you we use
them as house plants and stuff if you go
look at the pine cones of these things a
lot of times they're infested with
beetles and these beetles are eating
pollen they are pollen predators and
you'd think this is horrible this
thing's being attacked by these pollen
predators that would have been horrible
early on in this relationship but when a
plant is having its pollen eaten any
mutation that makes its pollen grains
stick to a predator actually might end
up being beneficial for that plant
whether it grows hairs on it that end up
sticking to hairs on the predator or
it's actually just physically sticky
there's a you know thousand ways to skin
a cat right whatever mutation happens
that makes the pollen stick to these
predators when those predators go to the
next plant the next pine cones there's
pretty high chance they're going to
spread that pollen to the other plant
and if you think about that's a direct
line it's a lot more efficient than the
wind these predators are going to go
from one plant to another they're
searching for pollen but they're going
to go to the female pine cones as well
checking those out
you can actually get to the point where
there's a selection advantage for having
pollen predators better than the wind at
this point
when the predator is a more efficient
pollinator than the wind even despite
the fact that it's eating the pollen
large percentage of the pollen while
most of your pollen just spills on the
ground if you're wind pollinated
there's going to be a point in your
evolutionary history where you benefit
from being infested with these beetles
and so any cues that you were passively
transmitting before that the beetle was
picking up on maybe it's the color of
your pine cones maybe it's something
about the smell of the pine cones if you
can magnify any of those cues you're
going to get more pollen predators to
come you're going to get more efficient
pollination yeah yeah
that makes sense yeah
you get the evolution of a signal which
essentially describes why
you'd have these plants that reproduce
by using the wind they scatter what is a
lot of resources into the wind and then
it goes elsewhere and it's basically
like a shotgun technique where they're
just like i hope i hit whereas
at some point predators came and got
involved and basically a selection
process made it so that there was a
co-evolution between the two
then they have to uh produce way less
material it's not as costly
yeah once that happens where you can use
that energy in different ways such as
growing bigger or you know taking up
more of the uh the sun's rays or
whatever it might be yeah yeah if you
look at a flower flowers produce pollen
and a lot of pollinators eat pollen and
they also eat nectar
nectar you can think of as a bribe
because sugar is the easiest thing in
the world for a plant to make it makes
it by just sitting in the sun
pollen is pretty
biologically expensive for a plant to
make you can think of you know how how
might this have started out the flowers
you know plants bleed
and they bleed sugary substances well if
if an insect is looking for pollen and
it's also getting a nice tasty treat
there it might spend more time on that
tasty treat than eating the pollen but
it's also there and then it goes to the
next plant that looks the same it's like
oh that was good i drank all that the
sugary blood it's gone i wonder if that
other one has it the co-evolution of
this
is super fascinating the pollinators are
evolving to better detect the plants
that are good giving them good things
and the plants are evolving to give
better things to the pollinators to
bribe them and to make it very obvious
that they exist it was a co-evolution
happening
without a mind necessary this is
happening automatically through descent
with modification acted upon by
selection yeah
yeah i was going to say like if you're a
theist and you know as i said they
mostly accept evolution by natural
selection and
this is a wonderful thing i mean for me
it is a very serious argument from evil
kind of thing because i think natural
selection is very very very brutal but
right it can also be conceived as just
an incredible process that god would be
using so
it's amazing how like you get this
rhetoric where they try and portray
evolution the creationists do this a lot
and i've seen this from apologists who
push creationism they try and make out
that you you're either with god or you
accept evolution and that's just not
true like the vast majority of of
christians well not vast majority but
the majority do accept evolution finally
so a queue again
we're definitely over driving this point
home but i think it's important because
it's such a cool concept and it actually
does take a while to wrap your head
around a cue is any passive transmission
that a sender makes that can be detected
by another organism
a signal is any transmission actively
magnified by a sender because its
reception by a receiver
helps the sender better survive and
reproduce
in the case of that psychic plant being
detected by a pollen predator actually
helps it survive and so it starts
magnifying evolution drives it to
magnify those signals it's magnifying
the cues that the beetle was already
using to detect
so it just magnifies those and they're
transformed into a signal signals can
develop when two or more thinking
entities are motivated to cooperate so
zoe and i we're motivated to cooperate
signals can evolve when two or more
evolving entities are under selection
pressure to cooperate it becomes a
co-evolution
process just a quick question related to
the signals
if you have the
well the natural selection that happens
within our bodies so that you know
you've got a production of testosterone
that is sending signals for the growth
of the beard is it any different inside
an organism
as opposed to outside of the organism
where the you know you've got like two
different organisms that are interacting
or you've got two different parts of the
dna within someone that's interacting i
don't know if i'm using the right
language here but hopefully you get the
question yeah yeah is there anything
different in terms of signaling it's
actually the same thing you have
different entities inside the body that
are physically apart from each other
there's information that one has that
the other could benefit from and there's
transmitting that it's
it's really the same thing the point of
encoding and decoding is to transmit
messages
through some sort of a channel that
could not otherwise be transmitted
without encoding and decoding it really
is the same principle one of the things
that happens inside the body is that you
have a lot more there's more selection
pressure to cooperate within a single
organism than there is between any two
organisms because you're the same
organism like the the whole thing either
dies or lives together there's no
there's no ambiguity there
the big difference here is that
selection pressure to cooperate is much
more intense within the body between
bodies right here's an example of a
signaling system that's hijacked this is
now coercion this is a flower that's has
evolved to seduce a bee into mating with
it so the bee gets no no nectar nothing
doesn't eat any pollen he just humps
this thing and then flies away and
here's a bee actually doing it
it thinks that's a female because the
the plant sends out a molecule that's so
similar to the female hormone that it
thinks it's met a female an estrus
so that's called it's actually not
called communication and biology that's
called coercion
see yeah because it's not
yeah one of them is mistaking
um
the signal and so as you said you don't
have the communication like that yeah
well
saying that they're mistaking
is a little bit mistaken because i think
in general there's you could say that
there's mistaking happening like a
whenever a flower is sending a signal to
a pollinator it's basically if you want
to interpret what it's saying you'd say
it's saying come pollinate me the insect
is hearing come eat so there's always a
mistake if you want to really interpret
that but in this case the the b is being
taken advantage of and they actually
some sometimes they'll actually
ejaculate and
for a b that's a huge loss because sperm
is difficult for them to produce
it's a selective disadvantage for the
bee to participate in this we don't even
consider it a signaling system we
consider it a coercion system
we think that the bee is
being hurt by this transaction yeah okay
it's actually kind of hard to know for
sure because maybe maybe they're also
getting practice
yeah it seems like the
the interpretation is a difficult part
here it's like where there's bits of
ambiguity and like fair enough we might
not know the answers to these things we
can speculate they arise and whatnot
it's a bit like um if you take that
plant to be your dog in the bath
you like that bee uh misunderstood
what was happening but you didn't have a
cost whereas as you said that b does
because it's expensive for them to
produce sperm so
yeah yeah yeah and actually there was a
cost for me when when zoe started using
the signal falsely when she just wanted
attention that was a cost for me because
i'd get up from work and i'd lose my
focus and then i'd yeah my dog just
wants me to pet her like no that's
that's how this works
exactly so but that would so that's why
you used the word q i guess yeah it
started out as a queue it became a
signal and then when she started
misusing it the communication eventually
broke down because i stopped responding
to it and then she stopped transmitting
it because it was no longer useful you
can actually get these signaling systems
to break down so with these bees if this
really is sufficiently detrimental to
these bees the system will actually
break down eventually because there will
be selection pressure any bee that
happens to be able to distinguish
between a flower and a female will have
a huge selection advantage over males
that keep losing all their energy mating
with flowers
if it's too exploitive the signal will
actually break down the coercion will
break down so coercion dishonesty and
signaling is actually always kept in
check because of this the signaling
system will actually break down if it's
if it becomes obvious and the same is
true with language i mean someone keeps
lying to you stop listening to him yep
communication systems can emerge
naturally thinking minds are not
required to design them i think we're
cool with that right i am i don't know
if
i don't know if creationists would be
but um but yeah i i am like i can
absolutely see how all of these things
emerge that they don't you know just
just this
there's nothing to it
since darwin it just changes everything
it really does yeah it does it does i
mean the only new thing here that we're
really showing is that there's
co-evolution happening to formal
language is that you need that
co-evolution it can't just be one entity
it's got to be both of these entities
evolving in this type of uh arms race
for more clarity essentially yeah so on
that front actually this is a probably a
good thing to quickly emphasize is that
co-evolution in the name it's a
cooperative between two different things
whereas
you would think that if this evolved
naturally then you your mind might go to
thinking well at one point it must have
been one because that's simpler
but i guess the way you could conceive
this is if we know that most thing well
early life didn't reproduce via sexual
reproduction they just they just split
and right you know that's what it was
you could have one thing and then it
splits and there's a slight difference
because if you know the information
isn't completely copied over perfectly
with the genetic mutation
and then you've got technically two
different things as long as they're
surviving and not being pulled out of
the um the gene pool from natural
selection
then you've got two things and that's
all you need to be able to eventually
better get this co-evolution between the
two and then you've got you've got your
language so i just wanted to put that on
the table because that's the way that i
would
i obviously don't know much about
biology but that's where i would
suspect that there might be an answer
there you do need two entities at least
two entities in order for this to work
for the emergence of symbol-based
communication systems these molecules
are symbols that are being passed in the
urine they're functioning as symbols
they don't mean anything outside of this
communication system right so like if
you smell the the dog you're in an
estrus it means nothing to you nope
means a lot to a wolf it means
everything to a wolf now i'm making the
the most technical argument
is that the genetic code is a simple
language it is a signal-based
communication system and this is where
we're gonna have to learn
some biochemistry so this is the thing
that we call a genetic code more
specifically this would be like a
dictionary for the genetic code and it
shows us the codons which are symbols
and it shows us the amino acids that
those symbols represent
and this is confusing for people to
think about when they first hear about
this because they're looking at a chart
that has letters on it and letters are
symbols so we we've got
symbolic labels for symbols
we're swimming in symbols here what is
going on
so i'm going to try and show this very
carefully here what the hell is
happening when i say that these are
symbols
so all of
our functional bits not all of them
our most interesting functional bits are
proteins these are the things people
call machines oftentimes because they
can they can get so complex so here i'm
showing a really simple cartoon version
of hemoglobin which is the protein in
our blood that can capture oxygen and
then release it when it's the time is
appropriate and that's what's inside of
red blood cells that's what gives them
their red color actually
so hemoglobin is this really complex
protein it's got multiple parts to it
it's it's giant protein
proteins are strings of smaller
molecules that are attached to each
other called amino acids
a bunch of amino acids line up in a
string and then they fold into a
particular type of protein
this is what the amino acids actually
look like so there's my silly cartoon
amino acids here's what they actually
look like in space filling model for
people that aren't used to seeing these
that's showing every atom in that
molecule so this is the amino acid
called arginine the label that we have
for arginine is the word arginine and
then the abbreviated label is arg those
are labels that we're putting on top of
this but it's actually a molecule the
colors here represent the types of atoms
so red is oxygen blue is nitrogen dark
gray is uh as carbon and
the white is hydrogen
that's the atoms atoms not really
colored
in real life but this is roughly the
actual shape of that of that molecule
here we have glycine it's another amino
acid much smaller much simpler
here we have serine so there are 20
different amino acids
that proteins in humans are made of
there are actually two more that some
organisms use that we don't yeah and i
think um in those uh experiments with
their biogenesis they may be even more
amino acids i'm not mistaken which is
fascinating as far as like that exists
in the world of chemistry there's yeah
there's i don't know how many there are
but there's lots yeah a bit of a trivia
for you in the bodybuilding community
you can get
glutamine powder
yeah it tastes horrendous that's what i
want to say
yeah you can buy all these because
certain certain diets will be low in
some some of them our bodies can
actually build we have the chemistry to
actually build them from pretty much
anything that we eat others we have to
eat full
it has to be in our food long story
short amino acids make up proteins
proteins make up living cells cells make
up tissues tissues make up organs and
then there's you right so that's
the thing the big question is how how do
amino acids
line up to form specific proteins and
that is the job of protein coding done
by dna that's the thing that dna does
that's the thing that the genetic code
does it allows genes to communicate to
the ribosome which is the protein
building machine and it tells them
specifically how to build a specific
type of protein so now we're gonna we're
gonna look at a quick little clip from
it's actually the first animation i ever
did first aided clearly
from what is dna and how does it work
this here is a simplified model of dna
it shows us that the steps of the latter
are made up of four different kinds of
chemicals shown here by different colors
and letters
if you look at just one half of the
molecule you can read its chemical
sequence
from top to bottom sort of like a book
a single strand of dna is extremely long
millions of letters long it spends most
of its life coiled up like a noodle
living inside the nucleus or the
centerpiece of a cell
amino acids however live outside the
nucleus in what's called the cytoplasm
to help dna interact with the cytoplasm
and convert those amino acids into
proteins
special chemicals inside the nucleus
make partial copies of the dna called
rna these partial copies look a lot like
dna but they're shorter of course and
they're missing one of their sides
their small shape and size allows them
to fit through tiny pores in the nucleus
out to the cytoplasm and into the mouth
of another particle called a ribosome
ribosomes are protein building machines
they read the rna three letters at a
time
suck amino acids out of their
surroundings and stick them together in
a chain according to the rna code
as the chain grows it bends it folds and
it sticks to itself to form a perfectly
shaped protein
every three letters of the rna tell the
ribosome which of the 20 different kinds
of amino acids should be added next
for example caa tells the ribosome to
grab a glutamine
agu tells it to grab a serine and so on
once a protein is built it can then go
on to do a number of different things
one of which could be to help form a
brand
new
cell
here is dna
we just saw in that animation that every
three letters i called it the rna code
in that video which is wrong it's the
genetic code every three letters in that
rna
represent an amino acid it tells the the
ribosome to grab a specific amino acid
so what do i mean by letters
obviously there aren't actually letters
in dna so letters are labels that we put
on actual molecules that exist
subparticles of a chain of dna and these
represent the molecule thymine cytosine
adenine and guanine so that's
tcag and in rna it's a little bit
different you've got uracil instead of
thymine it changes to uracil in in rna
and rna is also single stranded
tends to be messenger rnas are single
stranded so
those
things those nucleotides those are
molecules so this is what guanine looks
like in space filling mode so guanine is
this molecule this is what cytosine
looks like in space filling mode every
three sets of nucleotides is what we
call a codon
it's a set of molecules so that's the
ggg codon it's three of these
nucleotides the g nucleotides next to
each other the
c g codon if we draw in a more realistic
form would look like that these are
three-dimensional structures
these have been adopted as symbols in
the genetic code that their ribosome
recognizes the ribosome recognizes
ggg as a symbol for
glycine
when it's reading a chain of rna and it
grabs that three-dimensional shape that
three-dimensional shape changes its
structure allowing it to grab glycine
out of the environment
this involves another molecule called
transfer rna as well i'm not going to
complicate things by going into that
here though this is a physical process
in your video you say that this language
is just physics and so it's not really a
language all languages are based on
physics right i'm i'm making noises with
my mouth right now this is actually
something i didn't know very well um and
that you've helped me with like
absolutely understanding that no these
things are all physical it's just very
easy to not see them as such because
it's the way that they present
themselves so yeah that's also a very
good point that you've definitely
switched my mind on the thing is that
your brain has to be set up in advance
to interpret these
physical things that i'm sending you
these physical sound vibrations
your brain has to be set up in advance
to essentially know what those mean
the meaning has to be established in
advance and that's what's happened
between the messenger rna and the
ribosome there has been a long
evolutionary history establishing the
meaning of these symbols these three
nucleotides guanine guanine guanine
really are a symbol
representing glycine in the genetic code
on the actual chart here i've got the
ggg highlighted in pink over here and
i've got it circled
and that represents glycine and so this
shows you how this code chart works
ggg represents glycine and you also
notice here that there's a bunch of
other codons that can also represent
glycine
there's redundancy in the genetic code
it's robust there are certain mutations
that you can suffer
that won't change
the sequence
of a protein that your your specific
gene codes for because there is some
redundancy in the genetic code the other
important thing to point out here here's
arginine which is a different amino acid
and it's represented by cytosine guanine
cytosine so it's a different codon that
codes for arginine
and and so on you can go all the way
down this thing and then you have start
codons so aug that tells the ribosome to
start building protein at this part in
the the message so it clamps on and
starts building so everything after that
aug
is going to be part of the protein
actually aug will be part of the protein
too that actually goes for an amino acid
and then it's going to keep on building
this protein
which bends and folds sticks to itself
to form this three-dimensional specific
shape
until it reaches a stop codon
which there's three different stop
codons there's uaa uag and uga if the
ribosome hits one of those it's going to
fall off of the chain of rna and the
protein is going to be released it's
done building that protein
there's syntax in this language
there's start to the stop you have to do
things in order or else it's not going
to work so we have symbols and we have
syntax those are two linguistic traits
so when a creationist calls us a
language whether or not they understand
what they're even saying
well yes see i would say that it depends
on how they're defining language yeah
but yes like
absolutely that is a language and again
most paralysis would the tradition is to
call it a code but even if you look at
programming if it's a simple programming
language people could a lot of times
call it a code if it's complex we'll
call it a language it's it's just kind
of there's not an official cut off here
but
just to really dot the eyes and cross
the t's here i think it really does just
come down to that definition of language
because if someone wants to define this
as as the way that we've unpacked before
as john lennox and
ken ham does then it's just it's just
wrong to say that this is necessarily a
language yeah they've got all their work
ahead of them to prove it whereas if
they if they use the proper definition
well all the contention's going to be on
whether or not that can emerge naturally
and the evidence very much indicates
that it does again i want to say it's
not biologists all use the same
definition that
is perfect to use here it's that if we
look at all the different types of
definitions that people are using for
language the genetic code has linguistic
properties you could argue that it's not
a full-on language the way that english
is because it's so much simpler like
think about okay this is our dictionary
here this genetic code it's only like 64
words long english has how many over a
hundred thousand
most english speakers know that they use
something like 20 000 i think and then
they know like 40 000. compare that to
this language it's only got it's only
got 64. it's ridiculously simple
compared to english incredibly simple so
simple in fact that you could make the
argument that we shouldn't call it a
language we should call it a code yeah
and then most biologists call it a code
they don't call it a language but it
really does have these linguistic
properties those properties specific
properties being that there are symbols
here real symbols
and that there are syntax rules here the
order of things matters those are the
two ways in which it's correct to say
that this is a this is a language and i
think to admit that and agree with them
on that
yeah i think that's
the standard genetic code was cracked in
the mid 60s and then the researchers got
the nobel prize in 1968
for discovering this genetic code and if
you think about it like this could have
been arranged in actually not just
millions of different ways not just
trillions of different ways i think it's
like 10 to the 84
to the power of 80. so like 10 with like
84 zeros behind it something like that
possible different codes that could have
come into existence but this is the one
that we have so when we say that these
codon assignments are made arbitrarily
they're made really arbitrarily
they could have been made in a bunch of
different ways there actually are some
organisms that use a slightly different
version of the genetic code there are
different symbols that they use
so like we said another property of
language is that you can you can not
speak the right language and then it can
cause miscommunication our mitochondria
use a slightly different genetic code
than the nucleus of the cells and so if
a gene from the nucleus is used in the
mitochondria it can be misread so there
can be miscommunication because of the
language barrier in that case yeah yeah
so a thing i wanted to emphasize here
because i can i can i can feel in the
in the ether that some minds are going
here the fact that it can be
it could have been so many different
ways right right but we've got one
specific way a lot of theists i've
noticed especially if they are
sympathetic to the fine-tuning argument
which teleological arguments creationism
in general is
they tend to look at it and go see the
fact that there were all these different
ways that it could have come up but it
came up with this one way
uh is evidence that it was selected
intelligently to do so and i just want
to say that a good analogy or an energy
that i like is if you roll a six-sided
dice and you roll it five times in a row
and you try and predict what you know
you go all right i'm gonna get a six a
six a six a six and a six
the chances of that happening is one in
about seven thousand seven hundred and
twenty four if i'm not mistaken yeah the
thing is if you had said oh i'm gonna
get a one a three a three a five a four
and a six guess what the chances of that
coming up was is exactly the same yeah
and so it's very easy i find for people
to look at something and imbue it with
something more meaningful because it has
this there could have been so many other
numbers that came up when actually
it it just follows the it's not
all of the numbers are that rare the
only thing that matters here is that the
the sender and the receiver have an
established
meaning for a symbol right
that's that's what matters there's it's
been established you could take a gene
that already exists you could completely
change the genetic code change all these
rules that are on this chart yep you
could see how you have to edit the gene
so that it still works exactly the same
way as it did before because you just
change the the nucleotide sequence in
the gene and because these things
co-evolved they co-evolved together it's
just like english like i learned english
as i was a kid
that's what my parents were speaking new
genes that come into existence they're
going to have beneficial functions if
they use the genetic code to code for
something that's functional right
they're under selection pressure they
don't get to reinvent the language right
yeah the language was established in the
distant past it's pretty much unmutable
now it's not completely immutable like
it has changed in some organisms
slightly but very slightly actually it's
almost universal the really important
things to drive from this point that
codon assignments were somehow made in
the past
now this brings us to the big question
the big question that a lot of people
who are here really want to hear me
answer and that is how the heck did the
genetic code evolve this if you recall
is the question that carl rose had he
wanted to know how codon assignments
were made somehow these codons were
assigned to represent specific amino
acids how did that happen well we know
from earlier that signals can evolve
when two or more evolving entities are
under selection pressure to cooperate
this here is a space filling model of
the ribosome you have the top part and
the bottom part which clamp onto a
messenger rna and read that rna to the
right i have some transfer rnas these
are the molecules that bring amino acids
to the ribosome so that it can actually
build a protein as it's reading the
chain of messenger rna here we have
multiple different entities that are
capable of evolution these are large
biomolecules mutations can change their
shapes mutations can change how they
function one of carl woese's big
discoveries that wasn't fully his
discovery but one of the things he
really drove home is that the functional
bits of all of these parts here the
transfer rnas and the ribosome itself
the functional bits of these molecules
are made of rna so
in this model here the blue parts those
are protein and everything that's sort
of this yellowish pink all of that is
rna this is really unusual for
biomolecules in our bodies most
biomolecules most of the functional bits
of our cells are made of protein
the ribosome is one of the big
exceptions to this its functional bits
are rna karl wells drove this point home
really hard
because there is this thing called the
rna world hypothesis that scientists had
already been talking about before he
drove these points home and the rna
world hypothesis it's still just a
hypothesis there's lots of aspects of it
that have not yet been worked out but
the rna world hypothesis is this idea
that before we had complex proteins
before we had dna we just had chains of
rna that were evolving the world that
they existed in probably did have amino
acids in it and it probably had short
chains of amino acids we wouldn't really
call them proteins because they weren't
evolved functional structures but we
call them peptides short
chains of amino acids really tiny
proteins you could think of them as so
this environment was somehow generating
chains of rna and it was somehow
generating short peptides and amino
acids
and the hypothesis proposes that these
chains of rna could replicate and it has
been shown through experiments that
chains of rna can replicate under
certain conditions so far we haven't
found prebiotically plausible
environments that will allow chains of
rna to be produced and then to replicate
so that's one of the big problems of the
rna world hypothesis but chains of rna
can evolve they are evolving entities
and so it is not difficult to understand
loosely in principle how the genetic
code could have evolved of course the
details are not worked out but let me
give you just a really really general
scenario
just a quick apology i haven't yet done
an animation on the evolution of the
genetic code so
pardon the makeshift graphics that i'm
using here i'm going to rig this
together with bits of animation from my
rna world video along with some still
images to fill in the gaps
strands of rna all on their own without
any sort of protein they're not very
stable if they exist in an environment
that fluctuates in temperature or
fluctuates in ph they can break apart
pretty rapidly and what this means is
that very early on the types of
mutations that would have been selected
for are mutations that allowed a chain
of rna to become more stable
one way for a chain of rna to become
stable is to fold in and base pair with
itself and form these glob-like
structures so it's a chain of rna but
under certain conditions it will fold in
and attach to itself into a glob and
these globs are a lot more stable than
loose chains of rna would be the
ribosome does this the modern ribosome
folds into a glob it's actually chains
of rna that it's made out of and those
chains fold into globs that are nice and
secure
and another type of mutation that would
be selected for is the ability to grab
onto other molecules in the environment
and use those to stabilize its own
structure again the modern ribosome is
also doing this it attaches itself to
proteins to stabilize its own structure
that's what these blue parts are here in
this drawing they are proteins that are
stabilizing the ribosome structure and
by the way when we do rna experiments
just rna evolution experiments we see
chains of rna evolve towards glob-like
structures and we see them evolve the
ability to attach to other molecules so
we know from laboratory experiments that
replicating chains of rna are capable of
evolving both of these functions it's
super easy it happens almost immediately
when you start an rna evolution
experiment
so if you grant that there were at one
time chains of evolving rna or something
similar to rna and by the way even if
you don't want to grant this that's fine
because there's lots of other scenarios
that would work for this as well right
now scientists don't know exactly what
the early life situation was
lauren williams who's one of the big
researchers studying the origin of the
ribosome all the models that he builds
they don't require the rna world
scenario but if you grant for example
that there were chains of rna evolving
evolving in true darwinian fashion i
mean descent with modification acted
upon by selection these chains of rna
were replicating and there were random
peptides being generated by the
environment you would have had lots of
chains of rna that had evolved to fold
in on themselves into nice little stable
globs and you would have lots of chains
of rna that have evolved to grab onto
small peptides in their environment so
the rna world would have been full of
these types of critters these
glob-forming critters and these
protein-grabbing critters
all of the rna critters that need to
grab onto peptides these mini proteins
they're going to be in competition with
each other these peptides are going to
be a limited resource
rna chains that happen to be slower at
binding
well
they're out of the game
at the core of the ribosome we find bits
of rna that are able to grab amino acids
and essentially smash them together to
form a short peptide or depth peptide if
hydroxy acids are in the mix as well
the automatic consequence of building
these peptides is that these little
proto-ribosomes always have plenty of
peptides to stabilize their own bodies
they never really run out and early on
this would have been done randomly
they'd be grabbing either short chains
of amino acids or maybe single amino
acids and smashing them together to form
chains and these would be random amino
acids that they're grabbing there's no
control there's no there's no protein
coding happening they're just grabbing
whatever there is
smashing it together
even just this little core bit of the
ribosome is already something that would
be better at surviving than other random
chains of rna
once you have little peptide making
machines floating around in the
environment the door is open for
co-evolution this is because simple
peptide makers don't stop making
peptides once they have enough for
themselves they keep going indefinitely
and they go as fast as they happen to
come across amino acids
other chains of rna can help themselves
by helping the ribosome collect amino
acids and form peptides
so here we have an explanation for why
the core of the ribosome might have been
selected for early on and why other
chains of rna i'll call them amino acid
finders
could have been selected for early on to
help themselves by helping the ribosome
so you've got multiple little rna
organisms exploiting the ribosomes
abilities and the genetic code could
have evolved
under selection pressure for these teams
to cooperate more and more efficiently
in the construction of proteins and in
the construction of proteins that are
more and more specific you start out
with very random proteins that they're
able to build and then as more and more
players join in and compete in the
highly competitive ribosome feeding game
the system as a whole
gradually becomes more and more specific
in the types of peptides it can build
eventually the system's behavior can be
described with a chart like this a chart
that we call the genetic code
now that is
just a ridiculous cartoon version of how
this scenario could have played out in
the history of life
lauren williams over at georgia tech his
group recently published a wonderful
paper called root of the tree the
significance evolution and origin of the
ribosome much more of a big boy's
overview what is known about the
ribosomes origin and what is still a
mystery
word of warning it is a bit of a rough
read if you're not a biochemist but it
is definitely the place to start for
anyone who wants to dive in deep
but the thing that i want everyone to
understand including creationists
including atheists that are arguing with
creationists is that we know that
signals can evolve when two or more
evolving entities are under selection
pressure to cooperate
the ribosome in the entire translation
system is
made of multiple evolving entities that
are cooperating in the construction of
protein
in this case those evolvable entities
are messenger rna also known as genes
ribosomal rna and transfer rna
so
a message for our dear friends ken ham
and john lennox language can also emerge
through co-evolution
i suppose it's possible that jesus
designed the genetic code but it's also
possible the genetic code formed between
genes and ribosomes
as they co-evolved to build proteins
scientists are actively investigating if
it evolved exactly how that would have
happened they're actually doing real
research they're building models and
they're testing those models
creationists are doing nothing of the
sort instead they're just complaining
and misrepresenting the science
would this be a fair thing to say
in paley's time they were looking at
you know the structure of the hand
and they were saying we just do not know
how this emerged and it's fair enough to
say this really is a wonderful thing the
eye really is a wonderful thing like to
say that it's not a wonderful
biologically complex thing is just wrong
like no it is and that's where the god
of the gaps was
and then darwin come came along figured
it out and the refuge for god at the
moment is the gap that is the the the
ribosome
would you say that's a fair assessment
it's actually overly fair we understand
how signaling systems emerge we
understand that you need multiple
entities under selection pressure to
cooperate and you can get the evolution
of signaling systems it's the very
fine-tuned specific details that we
don't yet know about the origin of the
ribosome
well at the beginning you were saying to
me you're enco encouraging a still man
approach right which is something i
didn't take in my original video and if
we end here if we get to as we have now
here yeah i've given a still man and you
said that's more than fair it sounds
like we're probably on the right path
with the with the remaster i i just want
to
point out people that you can try and
read these papers if if you dare very
technical about the ribosome to
understand these papers you actually
need a
pretty well actually the the one the
root of the tree one tries to give you a
good understanding of the ribosomes
actual structure itself too to
understand these other ones you have to
really understand a lot about the coding
system there's a really cool paper right
here called what is code biology by
marcelo
i think it's an italian name barbieri
yeah probably i'm probably pronouncing
it completely wrong but he's arguing for
the the value and looking at biological
systems as codes
coding systems
you can study a coding system by its
mechanical bits or you can study it by
the code structure itself
you know you can study language by how
mouths move and vibrations are formed or
you can study it by how sentence
structure works and so on he's arguing
that we should actually spend more time
looking at biology from a coding
perspective from a linguistic type
perspective
he makes some pretty good arguments in
here i don't agree with everything he
says in there but he makes some pretty
good arguments there's a lot of value to
be had in this and it's not really
something we do most biologists focus on
the structures and physically how things
are happening people like dawkins who
were studying signaling in birds he was
really focused more on kind of the
linguistic side of what these birds are
doing but lauren williams he wrote the
one on the the root of the tree here
he's hyper focused on structure he
actually doesn't like thinking about it
all as code or as as linguists he just
wants to focus on the structure of these
things which is also fair it's a fair
angle to take there's a lot to be had
from both of these perspectives and
combining them
and then one other one
this is by a philosopher of of language
tc scott phillips who goes through and
talks really specifically about how
we think about
signaling in biology and why it's so
important to think about
things being adaptive before you call it
a signal he summarizes the work of
richard dawkins
stuart west
a bunch of people who have been focused
on signaling in animals and he does a
good job the jargon it's it's almost
like dude you're you're going too far
with this but it's it's important it's
important to go far with this when you
when you're trying this is just the
nature of these papers right like um you
get it with you know i read quite a bit
a few papers on metaphysics and the
jargon's just so rich it's
yeah
they've created their own language john
that's what they've done yeah yeah yeah
they have
honestly this whole process has been
just very edifying for me and um cool
yeah i absolutely do understand it more
and i feel like i understand it more
because when i tried to still man it you
said yes that's that's fair enough and
that's that's a good thing
yeah i will remake the video just thanks
for
for reaching out and all the rest of it
and also to the uh is it psy that you
mentioned
yeah inside managed to see his video
until very recently mainly because i
just no one had linked it to me or
probably someone had but i get quite a
lot of links and quite a lot of
responses but just yeah thanks for
making the video i appreciate it i'll
try and do a better job with this
remaster hopefully you can check it over
that would be funny yeah i'd be happy
i'm happy to pop in on it too sometime
if that'd be awesome that'd be really
really cool but mainly i just want to
say that um read through what i said at
the beginning john i really appreciate
your work
well thank you this was fun and as i
mentioned before it was just really cool
to have someone who's who wants to
actually like i made a video i publicly
made a thing about this if i admit that
i was wrong i get egg on my face but i
still want to do it because i'm
interested in understanding how this
works not not being right at all costs i
mean i almost want to call it heroic
even though it
might seem really flattering but it's so
freaking rare for people to do this i
used to think that there was something
special about religion that made people
unwilling to accept new ideas but
humans we are we are aggressive and not
wanting to change our thinking
yeah that lowly stamp isn't just a
remark against religion that isn't
that's that's on humans right um yeah
i've been through the same experience i
when i was young i thought maybe you
know other communities don't have it but
what i've realized as i got older is
this religion's not
a problem like someone's religion is
their religion it's none of my business
it's
it's the dogma and tribalism that
tends to be very present in religion but
it's not just religion you'll get it in
all sorts of communities
even in academia uh you don't have to
like just mention like politics and
whatnot
and a lot of it is to do with reputation
and preservation and to admit that
you're wrong on something is just it's
seen as a weakness in basically every
culture but um i i don't see it that way
i think i think it's a strength if your
goal is
truth
if your goal is figuring out what this
world's about whether or not there is a
god etc then um it just seems very
obvious to me that the right answer is
to just humbly admit you're not going to
know everything and you are going to
mess up and most importantly
that's okay right we're humans we're all
going to do it it's it's just part of
the process so
enjoy it when it happens like you know
you've calmly educated me here you know
i'm going to go home and cry it's it's
all brilliant thank you
cool yeah i appreciate it well thanks
for doing this this is fun
so long